machine learning has become the Talk of
the Town companies are pouring in
millions of dollars in building highly
Advanced infrastructures that can be
utilized to build and learn complex
machine learning algorithms and models
rightly so the demand for machine
learning professionals is at an all-time
high from Tech giants like Google to
design companies like canva the number
of job openings in the field of machine
learning is growing by the r and if you
want to build a career in this field
then joining a machine learning boot
camp might just be the right thing for
you to do according to recent studies AI
machine learning related job postings
have increased by 344 percent in the
past five years companies across the
globe are actively seeking professionals
who can harness the power of data and
build intelligent systems the average
salary is 150 000 in the US and 15 lakhs
per annum in India as the field evolves
new job titles and responsibilities are
anticipated to cater to Industry
requirements prominent companies like
Microsoft Google Amazon IBM Goldman
checks and apple are actively recruiting
machine learning Engineers hey everyone
welcome to simplelands YouTube channel
but before we dive into that don't
forget to like subscribe and share in
this video we'll discuss one of the top
machine learning boot camp you can
enroll yourself in to get started in
your career in the field of machine
learning there's no better time to train
yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you are looking for
a course that costs everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our Ai and machine learning
bootcamp in collaboration with Caltech
this Ai and machine learning bootcamp in
collaboration with Caltech will help you
advance your career as an AI and ml
specialist the AI and ml bootcamp
includes live classes delivered by
industry experts Hands-On Labs industry
relevant projects and master classes by
character professors so why to join this
amazing program the first reason would
be caltex academic Excellence earn a
bootcamp certificate and up to 22 CU
credits from caltex ctme
the next would be simple and career
resistance career mentorship and profile
building sessions with valuable insights
from industry experts and the next can
be campus immersion experience an
exclusive visit to caltex ctma campus
and then we have hands-on experience
that is 25 plus Hands-On projects across
industry verticals with integrated labs
this Ai and machine learning bootcamp
provides Caltech ctm is academic Pros to
help your accelerate your data science
career statistics python machine
learning deep learning natural language
processing and supervised learning are
all included in this Ai and machine
learning bootcamp so key features of
this amazing machine learning course
includes that is earn up to 22 cus from
caltex ctme and the next is online
convocation by Caltech ctme program
director the next is simple and career
service that helps you get noticed by
top hiring companies and you can earn a
boot camp certificate from Caltech ctma
then we have industry relevant Capstone
projects in five domains and the Caltech
cpme Circle membership then we have 25
plus Hands-On projects across industry
verticals with integrated labs and this
AI bootcamp leverages caltex academic
progress and help you pursue a strong
career in the domain of AI and machine
learning caltex Ai and machine learning
bootcamp is ideal for those looking for
a competitive advantage in the age of
new Cutting Edge Technologies the
curriculum provides a thorough grasp of
AI based Technologies like ml NLP deep
learning speech recognition
reinforcement learning and other topics
this a and ml course scores the latest
tools like tensorflow python Keras
opencv flask matplotlib nltk and many
more this AI enable program comes with
fantastic industry projects and five
domains like social media e-commerce
manufacturing Ed Tech and Healthcare so
hurry up and find the course link
mentioned in the description box for
more details the next quote is starting
soon to know more about this intensive
training program which imparts job ready
skills and prepares you for a career as
an AI engineer check out the link below
in the description box with this we have
come to the end of this machine learning
bootcamp for 2023. if you like this
video subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
update from Simply learn if you need
help opting for this course please let
us know in the comment section below
we'll get back to you as soon as
possible until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign